I don't normally do these kind of speeches
but this feels like a big moment.
I know it's not easy being banished
from MI5 to my department,
but that's on you.
Only screw-ups get sent to Slough House,
and I got to be honest
working with you has been the lowest point
in a disappointing career.
Right.
What are you looking for?
The remnants of a once promising career.
Slough House is like prison.
You’re not supposed to ask what you’re in for.
I actually want to be useful.
I could not be more bored if I tried.
You probably know how many
people have made it back
from Slough House to upstairs
here at Regent's Park.
Bringing you up to speed is like
trying to explain Norway to a dog.
None.
Come check this out.
Hostage.
He's being held here.
There is something finally happening.
What does it got to do with you?
Whatever's going on will be
handled by the real agents.
I get it. We're just slow horses.
I’ve got one lead. I have to follow it.
You're going to help me.
No, I'm not.
Like it or not, Slough House
is part of this now.
What do you think you're playing at?
I didn't mean to kill him.
Of course you didn't.
If you meant to kill him he'd still be alive.
You put lives in danger.
This is off the books!
I am directing personnel,
Yours or anybody else's.
She's covering her tracks.
It's the covering of the tracks
that always gets you in the end.
You really care about them don't you?
No. I think they’re a bunch of absolute losers.
But they’re my losers.